i'm here with my back-to-school crew
anisa
justin and linda
we have all signed up to uh get our ged
as you hopefully uh saw in the last
segment but we've landed ourselves in
the principal's office and he's not a
regular principal he's a cool principal
right it's principal ross matthew
principal matthews is in the hizzy as
the kids say um principal matthews what
do you have in store for us well you
know i really so proud of you are all my
best students you're also my only
students but
what kind of principle would i be if i
didn't have a little exam to make sure
that you've all been studying so i'm
going to throw some questions up on the
screen and read it out to you all and
since you're a crew you can all confer
and answer together are you ready we are
a crew and i'm very proud to be a part
of this crew i don't need a degree proud
to be in this crew
i know you guys have got this so let's
get started with question number one
drew's news is served sunny-side up we
all know that in this sentence what does
sunny side up mean
a it's all the good news you can use b
it's a newspaper served with bacon and
eggs c drew and ross only talk about the
news during the daytime or d it's all
news stories about eggs
i'm just kidding i i think you're right
i agree
i think you're probably all the above
because
i mean yeah i always talk about good
news so it's nothing yeah i would say
only above
all of the above well that's not going
to work on the real test
but
we were looking for a it's all
next question i love to talk to our
studio audience so if i talk to one
audience member for three minutes
how long would it take me to talk to an
audience of a hundred people would it
take a 45 minutes b two hours c three
hundred minutes or d would i lose track
of time because our audience is the best
i think i think i want to take this one
all right all right so
the original answer would be 300 but you
know since me in new york it's the best
audience so i'm going with d
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i just love watching drew's face when i
actually do a math problem she does this
ready this is her face
math is my achilles heel okay so the
question was exactly
three minutes to talk to one person so
if i talk to a hundred people how many
minutes would i be talking oh okay see i
wanted this is what i do to myself i
went into like for some reason it's an
hour so i was trying to multiply
60. clearly the answer is c 300.
that's right 300.
i
went down a complete rabbit hall well
you're doing very well i have to say i'm
proud of all of you here is our final
question
you all seen the movie e.t
well e.t boarded his spaceship and said
goodbye to gertie michael and elliot but
what when he left earth was the first
planet he saw when he left was it a
saturn b spielbergen c mars or d planet
um
b and c b and d is not a planet
oh gosh i well i just know that all the
powerful men are trying to get up to
mars
um
in their rocket right
so
i don't know why i feel saturn too i i
think i'm with justin well i i would
think it was mars because it's
mars okay
[Applause]
saturn's further away you did fantastic
you're all a-plus students
and uh we are all so proud of you and in
fact we put together a little surprise
video for you take a look at this
just finished your big sister brianna
and your older brother joseph so we just
wanted to let you know we are so proud
of you for doing your ged journey we
gonna always be in your corner just know
that hi anisa i knew when we got married
as teenagers you could do anything you
set your mind to it now here we are over
30 years later and you're doing it again
your kids and i are so proud of you
honey hi mom i know you've been really
worried since i joined the military um
but i just want to let you know that i'm
safe and i am so proud of you for
starting this amazing journey
and i
just can't believe how great you're
doing with your job and raising my
brother and doing all these classes at
the same time and you've been doing such
a great job with all your studying hi
drew i am so proud of you for going back
to school you're actually one of the
smartest people i know and the most
well-read and the most literate and the
most educated but i also love that you
never tire of learning and i'm so proud
of you for going on this journey and
taking others along with you i think
you're going to inspire so many people i
love you and go get them hit the books
[Applause]
how is it to see your daughter i miss
her so much
and i'm so proud of her i'm so
happy that
i am so happy for you i mean justin your
brother and sister are you just spoke
about
there they are rooting you on just to
see just see my older brother there and
just soak them awesome he's always he's
going to be always in my corner that's
something that it's hard woman and i'm
just glad i have my little brother and i
wouldn't change every word well i'd like
to include him
um
let's keep our families close um through
this your brother your daughter
and daughter wait a minute
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
it must be really lovely to see your
husband um so proud of you yes he's
always so supportive of everything i do
he just
he's incredible i love this this is so
good this is the good stuff in life you
know
um anissa justin linda thank you for
going on this journey with me i'm
terrified but i'm really excited to be
doing it with you
all right we'll be right back
[Music]
you